ruxandra jamba shoe keeps coming back
here to be close to her daughter Johanna
a doctor herself she can't understand
why you wanna had to die she was at a
concert in the bucharest collective
nightclub when it caught fire dozens
died in the ensuing panic Johanna was
lucky enough to escape but died later in
the hospital though not from her
injuries she died from an infection she
picked up in the hospital Melinda cada
semana forsakes that there are moments i
can hardly breathe and feel like
someone's digging claws into my chest in
another medical system Johannes chances
of survival would certainly have been
good and I say that not only as a
distraught mother my mother chance at
the cottage Joanna was brought to this
hospital with burns on her hand her
mother a surgeon who worked in the
hospital for 25 years blames her death
on disinfectant manufacturer hexie
Pharma and it's criminal accomplices it
wasn't negligence it was a deliberate
criminal act Johannes autopsy revealed
that the cause of her death was a
hospital-acquired infection with a very
aggressive multi drug-resistant bacteria
diluted disinfectant from antiseptics
manufacturer Hexy Pharma was to blame
the same disinfectant that had been
supplied to 350 Romanian hospitals for
years journalists catalin tolentine and
his team uncovered the scandal after
receiving a tip uno de fabrica a
Venetian adopted a documentary to the
file said a man from the factory came
and gave us documents proving the
falsification the ingredient list show
that the disinfectants were diluted
their deal what and not just one or two
products but all of them for more than a
decade as it jellies ooh la la they like
sport I want any more we're witness to
mafia style activities
the in which the authorities hospital
directors the Ministry of Health and
private companies are all in cahoots
with one another and that's angered
people holland tun brought samples of
the disinfectants to an independent
laboratory for testing the results
showed that most were heavily diluted
around ten times weaker than their
labels claimed kagaku content released a
Miami kumusta when the concentration of
active ingredients is lower the
disinfectants effectiveness is lower to
some of the bacteria fungi and viruses
are destroyed but the rest survive and
in most cases become even more
aggressive ultimately they can become
deadly that's why it's very dangerous
when disinfectants are not manufactured
as prescribed with the right
concentration of ingredients yellow
adoro Zack Sofia would ed Zack hexie
Pharma earned millions buying
disinfectants diluting and reselling
them just after the scam was exposed the
boss died in a car crash but many also
blame the Ministry of Health the number
of patients contracting bacterial
infections in the hospital has almost
doubled over the past decade but
officials refused to accept
responsibility consalvo go doc easy to
the respective HS anthem blood level of
education ministry can't comment or
express an opinion on how these
purchases were made on what exactly
happened as we don't have the means to
monitor all of this we only develop
health care guidelines a politically
chitosan adopted for ruxandra Jim Basu
who's founded an organization together
with other victims families that sounds
like mockery this is the biggest
healthcare scandal in Romanian history
one that costs the Health Minister his
job back in May the state prosecutor is
investigating the matter and roxana is
seeking justice for Jana and the many
other victims who have died in Romanian
hospitals
shorty it's a horrible irony of face
after 25 years of working in this system
my worst fears have come true go pro pro
CC moroco pilfered SF my one and only
child has become a victim of this system
international the context this system
has cost roxana jam basu her livelihood
as well she says she'll never be able to
work in a hospital again